there is the Sunday night slate of games
if you're watching on NBCSN we get
started again with the kickoff Packers
it bears on that Thursday night right
after Labor Day weekend Chris what we're
doing now though is we're going to
expand the lens beyond the games that we
will be involved in the broadcasting of
and we're looking at the best games now
that we know the when we've known the
who we've known the where you throw in
the win and you can really say these are
the best games of the year these are the
ones we are most looking forward to
we're gonna draft them now and I'm gonna
dispense with the coin toss I'm gonna
give you the first pick in this just as
I'm in a good mood today for what is
going on with the world I want the first
pick an hour from now when we have the
second no deals no deal we'll flip the
coin they're not not as nice as you I
don't feel like a good at mood as you
okay for my first pick you know I'm
gonna make this easy it's kind of I kind
of obvious but I'm gonna go right to
week two a lot of my matchups are gonna
be early season cuz I don't know what
the hell's gonna happen late in the
season so they might not be as good week
- okay Saint said Rams
yeah it's that obvious is kind of boring
I was okay I don't know if I really want
to pick that but am i excited why'd you
do it well because it's just so obvious
it's not boring it's just a little
obvious but I still think regardless I'm
excited to see it I mean these are two
head coaches that got a little chip enos
about him Shawn McVeigh this offseason
everybody's talking about all the Super
Bowl issues and he didn't adjust the
Bill Belichick Sean Payton who we know
is you know a chippy guy anyways he's
gonna be mad at how the season ended and
of course it's just a big matchup
between two NFC powers to wear
head-to-head matchups like this in week
two could be for the difference in
home-field advantage or the difference
between a wild-card team and a team that
has a first-round bye but since it's
early in the year I still think the
debacle of the NFC Championship game
last year will be fresh on the minds of
the players involved in the game and
it's still gonna have a personal aspect
that's why I like it that's why I start
right there first of all the fact that
you did not pick a game
involving Oh Aaron Rodgers is stunning
to me
we're always stunning I'm growing yeah
yes and and it's even more surprising
that you did not pick a game involving
the reigning MVP the best player in
football better than Aaron Rodgers sorry
Holmes the best player in the NFL right
now he's unlike anything we've ever seen
and how can you if you're gonna go with
a conference championship game hard to
go wrong with a conference champion how
in that I gave it to you I handed to you
and you threw it back in my face
Patriots hosting the Chiefs week 14
that is the game to watch this year that
is the game that that I will be looking
forward to from the moment the season
begins I want to see what my Holmes and
Brady can do because we saw it last year
in primetime
mahomes almost beat Brady it was that
throw to Gronk who's not there to save
Brady and the Patriots this year that
helped the Patriots win that game and
then in the postseason in Kansas City in
overtime the Patriots go right down the
field and win the game who knows maybe
the rule will be different by the time
they play in week 14 maybe in May
they'll make it that if you score a
touchdown on the opening drive of
overtime the other team gets a chance to
match it or beat it so I it's a
no-brainer man Patriots Chiefs getting
together in Foxborough week 14 yeah I
mean who knows week 14 they could both
be out of the playoffs and it can't be
that very good of a game so yep I mean
great big bite you I mean they both
could be just you know on the edge of
being in I don't know that's I can't
tell the future that far that's why I'm
going early season matchups those teams
might not even be good by then okay
great you really think the Patriots who
have been to the AFC Championship game
every year since before you retire right
yeah this is going to is not going to be
in the playoff hunt in week 14 is that
what you're telling me in the vision
with the bills the Jets and the Dolphins
they're not gonna be in the play I think
that's a tougher year in their division
this year I think this will be one of
the tougher years they've had but know
if they give you made me bet I would
think that they're going to the playoffs
yes and getting ready to make a deep run
so okay we'll see you know I don't know
about that one I've I've I've had
I've heard okay here's another one that
really gets me excited how about like
the first Sunday night football game in
Cleveland week three Rams at Browns I
got to go with this again I don't like
picking repeat teams but this is still
the Los Angeles Rams Super Bowl
contenders obviously Super Bowl
participants last year
big-time star power best defensive
player in the game got Brandon cooks
Gulf Gurley everything to go along with
it all that personality Aqib Talib and
Marcus Peters what verse Odell Beckham
jr. and Jarvis Landry and Baker Mayfield
you think there's gonna be some talk and
chatter and that football game let alone
the dog pound is gonna be going
absolutely berserk for a Sunday night
game with the reigning NFC champs coming
into town and really a big moment for
the Cleveland Browns to kind of give
their stamp of approval or whatever it
may be they say hey we're here Cleveland
fans we're here we're a real team this
year we're not gonna be some fluke so
that was one that I certainly perked up
when I saw that early on in the season
okay now now this is I cannot believe
that you are doing this because you've
had two picks now neither game that
you've selected involves Oh Aaron
Rodgers neither game that you've
selected involves Patrica holmes-sama
Tate was like it was just a half-hour
ago that you called week eight packers a
Chiefs the game of the year
how in the hell have you skipped over
that game twice well I was gonna go
there's Chiefs
I didn't mean it was game of the year I
meant it you know for me it's very I was
gonna go there next probably but I think
as a total thing yes I wasn't sure we
don't know what the Packers are gonna be
I can understand game of the year can
have different meanings I can understand
that that can be a very ambiguous in
vague term I don't know when someone
says game of the year maybe they think
well I don't know maybe it's gonna be
okay but that's one potential meaning of
the term game of the year
Packers Chiefs week eight Sunday Night
Football book it that's gonna be you I
can't believe are you sure you feeling
okay today are you did you did you stay
up I got your maybe
maybe I should have picked that the
second round maybe I should have you're
right it's my two favorite players in
the game right now I'm not gonna say
Patrick mahomes is better than Aaron
Rodgers yet okay I gotta see it for one
more year or at least a half a year
before I make that determination but it
is the first time I'll admit Mike and
about I'm gonna say what since 2009
where I'm going into a season going oh I
don't know if Aaron Rodgers is the best
quarterback in football because 2010 is
when he changed my mind and I was like
oh this is the best quarterback in 2011
it became whoa this is not even close
he's definitely the best quarterback and
it's kind of been that way ever since so
he's got some competition at the top
there and I know you think our homey
Patrick mahomes is the guy that's the
the best player in the league right now
so I get you there
all right week three I mean my third
pick I hate to do this okay but I mean
why can't I pick the opening season
Sunday Night Football game that's where
I'm gonna go it seems like I'm a
homework because I'm working for NBC now
but I really look at New England
Pittsburgh Pittsburgh going to see the
New England Patriots the rivalry right
there I mean I just thought that was a
brilliant game to start out Sunday Night
Football brilliant for NBC brilliant for
the NFL in general you know just there's
too many big storylines there's too much
tradition with both franchises I think
everything around it is going to be an
awesome matchup
I think Pittsburgh yes we've talked
about it a lot is gonna feel a little
disrespected probably going into the
season New England's gonna be hanging
another banner and the place is gonna be
in a frenzy because it's the sixth Super
Bowl and this is the run for seven this
year and all of that so these are two
franchises who have six Super Bowls and
it's a bit of a personal battle so as
obvious as it might be I'm gonna pick it
because it gets my blood boiling just as
much as any matchup by watch or see yeah
and I think it's a nice break from that
week 15 the last couple of years ride it
right out of the gates and let's see
these two teams get together and that is
gonna be one of the best games of the
year and that was one of the candidates
for me as we get into round three but he
one last year that I thought was a game
that that we you know sometimes we'll
have outcomes that we just did not
expect and the Saints were racking up
points like I I can't recall ever seeing
a stretch where there were just so many
points and it was pinball machine type
production by the Saints and then they
ran into a brick wall in Dallas on
Thursday night yeah a week after
Thanksgiving and that was the moment
where people started to wonder what's up
with Drew Brees although you could argue
that Drew Brees wasn't the same guy
weeks before that week for this year the
Cowboys at the Saints and I don't last
year the Saints desperately wanted to
face the Cowboys in the playoffs in New
Orleans there's something about that
building in Dallas we started to hear
Pete Carroll talk publicly about it last
year
privately I've heard plenty of concerns
that the Cowboys pushed the limits for
all that all the lights and they they
bring you through the nightclub and it
just distracts the players in a way that
no other opposing venue distracts
players and the Saints are gonna get the
Cowboys in their ability and my guess is
the Saints maybe he will have beefed up
by the time the season rolls around the
things they do to distract visiting
players before a game and you throw in
that that lingering rumor and I know
Sean Payton addressed it last week and
what's he gonna say still the coach of
the Saints they asked him about coaching
the Cowboys he's gonna say yes I can't
wait to coach the Cowboys it's not gonna
go away the notion that at some point
Sean Payton will be the coach of the
Cowboys and this is the year where the
changing of that guard could come where
Jason Garrett would be out and maybe
Sean Payton would be in so I think that
makes for one of the great games of the
season yeah I mean it was one of the
great games of the year last year even
though it was a low-scoring game it was
physical it was fun to watch I mean I
really enjoyed it you're right the
dynamic gets changed with it being away
from Dallas and in in New Orleans and
I'll even throw another little you know
aspect that jumps out to me I mean this
could be a big game early on in the
season you look at both team schedules
Dallas has a fairly comfortable first
three weeks where you know I don't know
if they come out three and no but I can
sit here right now and go their team is
more talented than the first three teams
they play on their schedule New Orleans
on the other hand man they got some
schedule
to start out before they got to play
Dallas in week four yeah you know it's
the Houston Texans at home like you said
earlier a playoff team Dashon Watson
that defense they're the real deal
then they got to go to the at Los
Angeles Rams then they got to go to the
Seattle Seahawks and then you got home
against the Dallas Cowboys wow that is
some stretch and yeah I mean the Saints
could be fighting for we need to be two
and two here or something like that to
where I think it even makes it more
intriguing and they've had two
consecutive devastating ends to their
playoff runs and they're back in that
valley of zero and zero is Dennis Green
used to call it and they have to dig
their way out we talked earlier about
the importance of winning games early in
the season and the draft we do an hour
from now we'll focus on the toughest
early stretches because your season
could be over before it barely begins
one last thing before we technically I
know we're a little bit over here yeah
but this is an example of how the
schedule can influence what we think of
a game Chris because bills at Cowboys
who really cares bills and Cowboys on
Thanksgiving I almost made that my
third-round pick I did Josh Allen in
Dallas in that spot yeah and you play
that game on Thanksgiving in that late
afternoon window and all of a sudden
that is a much more compelling game I'm
with you man you know me I'm on this
Buffalo bandwagon I really am I believe
in McDermott I believe in being the GM
I'm a big Josh Alvin fan their defense
is the real deal you know there's a lot
of things that's why I think like New
England this is the first year I go in a
long time going this is not a cakewalk
in the AFC this year not with Brian
Flores in Miami and the Jets and Buffalo
are are on the right during their
trending the right way so I'm excited to
see how that all plays out all right
quick break when we return the teams
apparently were commissioned by the
league to come up with the best online
schedule announcements that they could
we'll talk about some of the best ones
we saw when PFD live continues
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports